we're out here by the Computer History
Museum in Mountain View California the
Google headquarters is just around the
corner
but before we start to build our
applications on the Google cloud
platform let's look at the history of
building server-side applications 15
years ago
this is where most server-side
applications were born on a physical
computer sitting under the desk in some
office yeah seriously a physical
computer you know one that you could
touch and smell and that generated heat
from the fan outlet so you could warm
your feet if the office was cold well it
didn't take long until the server-side
applications grew bigger and it was no
longer possible to run them on a
computer like this so the pizza box
computer was created because it looked
like a pizza box and these were great
because you could stack them on top of
each other and on top of each other and
on top of each other and voila the
computer rack had just been born and the
entire shebang was put in a dedicated
room called the data center because all
the fans made too much noise and stuff
but it was no longer possible to warm
your feet against the fan-out that of
course